if your life was a movie genre which one
would it be in
why probably like a dramedy you know
little comedy you know but also like
some hard-hitting things drama every now
and then I don't know gossip I don't
know film Noir W that's nice was that
surprise you no that actually makes a
lot of sense and there something Smokey
and I like that mystery mine would be a
horror movie straight up slasher film
well a musical right because there's
always music in everything the whole
place is just a bunch of Rhythm and
Harmony and dissonance tension and
resolutions it's all music right uh a
horror movie because it's I'm all about
intensity and I think the way I describe
my life is a perfect mix of ignorance
and adrenaline and I think that's how a
horror movie seems to me
noir cuz I'm dark and mysterious a dark
comedy a very dark comedy a surrealist
comedy my life would be a drama for sure
uh a serious adult drama epic in scope a
globe trotting adventure with lots of
romance and
[Music]
mystery